- Good morning, Believe Nation, it's Evan,
my one word is believe, and I believe
that you have something special
that, when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message
is write it all down.
Over to you, Joe Rogan.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso get me goin'
♫ I wake up every morning'
- Write down everything you want to do.
And I don't mean crazy like I want to be
the Prince of Brunei, I'm going
to have a base on the moon.
Shut up.
This is what I want you to do.
Write down what you would
like to fix about your life.
If you're 30 pounds overweight,
you want to lose 30 pounds,
do it the right way,
start eating vegetables,
monitor your calories,
write down what you eat,
exercise every day,
force yourself to do it.
Say, you're the General.
The brain is the General,
the troops are the body,
the troops don't want
to listen but you listen
and you get up, and you do it.
And then you get to write it down.
And if you don't write it
down, you don't eat, you don't,
you don't jerk off, you don't shower,
you write that, down so you do it.
It's like brushing your teeth.
It's not like, "Eh, I don't
want to brush my teeth today."
What, do you want your teeth
to rot out of your head
you, dunce, just do it, just
do it, make yourself do it.
And if you do that, if you
write, down and do that,
you can change who the, you are.
- I'm a big believer
in writing things down,
I have my goals down, my big
goal that I want to accomplish,
but also my weekly goals
and my daily goals.
I wake up, I know what I have to do today
because it's written down
in my Google calendar note.
And I think this is a key difference
that can really help
a lot of entrepreneurs
is understanding planning versus doing.
I think too many
entrepreneurs are constantly
in planning mode, and it's
fine to be in planning mode,
right, you're planning, you're
thinking, you're dreaming,
you're imagining, here's
how I'm going to start
and then we're going to hire this person,
then you keep building this
great idea, it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger and
bigger, and it's exciting.
You fire off the happiness feelings
of this great idea that
you're exploding out.
But nothing happens until you do, right?
And sometimes the planning
and the seeing it to the end
is so exciting, it's so fulfilling,
but then you don't even want to do it
because you already got the
happiness from doing that,
and you don't actually
want to do any of the work.
Where most entrepreneurs,
I think, are up here
with planning and like
down here in execution.
You got to flip it.
Planning is really important.
You don't want to just go out and do
and hope something happens, right?
That's not the path to having success.
So planning is important but
doing is way more important.
Like, you got to spend way
more time on the execution
versus the planning, and so this is why
writing things down really helps.
So when you're in planning
mode, and whether it's
once a week, or once a
month, or once a quarter,
or some kind of mixture
of whenever you feel like
your plans aren't going according to plan,
you create a new plan.
And say, okay, Monday I'm going to wake up
and here's what I'm going to work on.
And when I look at my
Google calendar note,
and I wake up and I see
Monday and here are my tasks,
I know what my goal is,
like here's my big goal,
and then I know how I'm
going to accomplish that,
and then I know what I need to do today.
So, the planning mode is
super small on a Monday,
I'm just reviewing what
I need to get done,
and then I spend the entire day doing it.
Executing, making tons of progress.
How am I able to make three videos a day
for my YouTube channel?
Yes I have a team, yes
they help me tremendously,
and yes we have a plan in place, right,
of how to structure the
day and how to film,
and what goes up and content review,
and a whole system and architecture,
and we constantly work
to improve that plan,
but it's, most of the time
we're spending time doing.
Like, I am executing, Christine
and my editor is executing,
the people on my team are
executing, we're doing the work.
And so, you need to get
out of the planning mode
and more into the execution mode.
And if you don't write things down,
then you stay in planning mode
too much, at least I find.
If I woke up and I didn't know
what I was going to do today
and I didn't have a plan, then
I'd wake up and make a plan.
Right?
I'd make a plan, and then
start from the top again,
and then, I would spend a
good chunk of time planning
and not enough time actually doing.
And if I did that every day I'd be losing
so much time to planning
that I would never
get as much done as I could get done.
So planning is important, and you need
to spend time planning and you figure out,
what is your execution game plan, right?
Good.
And then most of your
time, 90% of your time
is spent actually doing the work.
And then you come back at some point like,
did this work work,
did it lead to results,
is this the best use of my time?
You can come back to planning
mode every now and then,
and make some adjustments
then go out and test it again,
but this is where you need
to spend most of your time.
The work, the doing, the
execution, the hard stuff.
Versus the planning, the
thinking, the dreaming only.
You need both pieces, but
you got to play more here
than over here.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious to what your habits
are of writing things down.
Do you write down your big
goals, your little goals,
do you have a daily to-do list?
What do you do to write things down
that helps your business move forward,
or is it a new habit that
you're going to start
after watching this video?
Let me know, leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm really looking forward
to hearing your thoughts.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Alex Smith
of Odd Angry Shot, Alex thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book "Your One Word",
it means a lot to me, man, and
I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- My infrastructure and
what I wanted to see myself,
I wrote, I write everything down.
And I see everything, so I
got books and books and books
from years that now I go back and pull out
and I'm like, wow, you said this in '09?
And now you're livin' it, you know.
- So you wrote the vision
and you like, make it plain?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And you see it, and you see it.
And that's one thing I share with guys,
I'm like, listen, write down your vision.
Write it, you know, let
your subconscious mind
be the leader of you,
you know what I'm sayin?
Trust it, because what you
think in your subconscious mind
is ultimately what you're going to live.
And that's when God says write the vision,
He said make in plain,
He didn't say write a
five thousand word essay,
He just said write it.
Make it plain so you can see it,
so you can visually see
where you want to go
in your next steps.
And so for me, I did that
a lot and I still do it.
- If you write your goals down
it makes all the difference.
Harvard did a study in 1973,
they took the graduating class
and asked them how many of them had goals,
100% of them had goals.
Well they asked how many
had written down their goals
upon graduation, only 5% of the class had,
and in 1993, 20 years
later, they followed up
with the class, they
found that the 5% that had
written down their goals 20
years prior upon graduating
were worth more financially
than the other 95%
of the class put together.
So I have always written my goals down
about what I wanted to
achieve, and I really attribute
a lot to that, and then aim high!
It's really true.
- So the most important thing you can do
is plan your day preferably
the night before.
Sit down with a piece
of paper and write down
everything that you have
to do the coming day.
It should be the last thing
you do at the end of the day.
Now if for any reason you don't do this,
then the first thing
you do in the morning,
before you check your
email, your phone calls,
newspapers, first thing
you do in the morning
is make a list of everything
that you have to do that day.
Once you have a list, you
have a track to run on.
Writing down a list
clarifies your thinking.
Writing down a list forces you
to think at a higher level.
If you are working from
a list you increase
your productivity and
output by 25% the first day.
All successful people work from lists,
and all successful people,
with regard to their projects,
work from checklists.
A checklist is a list of
everything organized in sequence,
and you go down the checklist.